before I started acting I had a very
successful executive right I had
six-figure salary made him lived a very
comfortable lifestyle I traveled
everywhere first-class have been all
around the world I mean I had the
greatest job and so but then I got bit
by this acting bug and I and I and I go
to my mom and I tell her listen I'm
thinking about quitting my job but I
think I'm quitting my job and moving to
Los Angeles and and becoming an actor
and fully expecting her to say have you
lost your F in mine would you get a
great life no one does that and my mom
you know she was in the she was in the
hospital at the time and she says to me
um she listens and she says go ahead you
know she says when you get older you
wish you took more chances and not less
and she says so if you're gonna go go to
LA and make me proud and I left that are
there like bawling because I'm living on
the East Coast and I know that moving to
LA I'm not gonna see my mom that much
anymore
right because of the distance and I
remember I'm on the plane and and I'm
flying you know flying out here to move
out here to Los Angeles and I'm just
ballin like the whole I'm just
I'm a mess and I remember the lady
sitting next to me thinking what the
Italy six hours I mean I'm just I'm
a mess and and subsequently you know not
too long after moving out here my mom
had like stage four cancer and then she
died so um whenever I think about you
know this business is too hard or I want
to quit or you know maybe I should give
it up I think about my mom's words to me
and I also think I'm I missed out on so
much because I was here and there was
many times where I didn't get to see you
and my mom and I were like this I mean I
did everything with her so there was so
many times I didn't get to see her
because I came out here to do this then
I give this everything I have
Wow okay sorry wow that was beautiful
thank you
you